whatever now you are both very
competitive we know this right and one
of the things you both do online oddly I
don't think we ever talked about this
but you both do it you post these kind
of motivational speeches and they're
short and punchy just to give people an
example this is will and they've always
done like this self-discipline is the
center of all material success what is
your contribution to the human family it
just other people's opinions is a really
shitty way to determine how we feel
about ourselves and that's all I'm going
to say about there I would say slightly
more aggressive is Kevin doing some wake
up door let's get back to smile let's
get back to lovin let's get back to be a
positive don't do what they expect you
to do do the unexpected
[Applause]
so we had the idea we've asked the
audience if there are any kind of issues
in their life that they need motivation
with something where you know their life
is stopping them and you guys can push
them over okay people do it
can we exclude her brother he's not I
mean just for the safety of the audience
okay
so let's find out who we're going to
first is it Galia Galia all right so you
have a fear you want to help egg it over
right yes I'm scared of feet but are you
scared of your own feet any feet my own
my friends any like I don't to look at
them see them touch by them okay okay so
so gamma is scared of all theatre feet
okay so I'm gonna start with you will
okay so the cut if you want to do it
straight down the lens it's number five
there okay so
Galia it's good if he how can you get
her over this fear go
this one's easy we don't fix this right
now you got to come down here and
confront your fear
[Applause]
okay
in a bizarre drug-related incident
Graham Norton was arrested over five go
camera five you know what it's it's what
was your name Acharya Galia Galia here's
the best way to get you over your fear
of feet
you can't take steps in life without
feet your fear is prohibiting you from
progression the minute that you can look
at feet and understand their feet are
simply would move you forward yeah you
will put your fear behind
[Applause]
rules like medication yeah okay let's go
let's go to Jackson where's Jackson now
Jackson is almost real so Jackson you
need motivation because I'm lactose
intolerant but I can't help myself I
keep eating dairy you can't just give it
up so you want to stop eating dairy
because it's bad for you yeah but you
can't yeah look there's plenty of
alternatives out there but let's be
honest they don't taste as good what
happens
well basically after I ate it I'm the
not so Fresh Prince of bel-air yes okay
easy
you know at some point you have to think
about other people
[Laughter]
you know if the lactose doesn't agree
with you it's not going to agree with
others and just at the heart of it if
you love anybody if you love anybody
especially those that are near you just
put the ice cream down because we we are
not inclined to enjoy your funky ass
[Applause]
okay okay I'm gonna I'm gonna go the
opposite the opposite route here's my
thing somebody didn't want to change
people want to do what you're supposed
to do
everybody's lactose-intolerant says you
know what I'm lactose intolerant and I
can't here's my feeling you get one life
and if you want to blow your ass
[Music]
[Applause]
you get one long yeah it's all set it
does go out saying I drink milk cuz I
loved it we'll need some sage advice
[Music]
you